and a warning it contains flashing
images from the start
Prince Harry's hatred of the British
tabloid press is no secret and now he
has them in his sights heading to court
as star witness in a long-running
litigation he claims the tabloids tapped
his landline and hacked his phone for
headlines experts say his case against
mirror group newspapers will be seismic
this will be a full contested trial of a
claim brought by a senior member of the
royal family against the British press
it will involve him being cross-examined
in the witness box
it will involve uh his um inevitably his
veracity being challenged so the
potential for disaster is immense I mean
it's just huge Prince Harry has a
handful of cases against British
newspapers but this the first to
potentially come to trial it is a joint
action with other well-known names but
none as high profile as Harry he says
148 stories were written about him all
using information obtained through
hacking more than the stuff about his
family yeah comes back to the press his
refusal to settle applauded by privacy
campaigners one thing this trial will do
whichever way it goes is the judge will
make a determination of who's telling
the truth and who did what when and as
the campaign to expose this activity to
the extent it went on that's what we
want we want the truth to come out the
trial starts just three days after the
coronation coming to the UK to appear in
court is a huge risk for Harry
it shows how far he'll take his fight
against the tabloids Laura bundock Sky
News